Almost Heaven
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Twitch-Emotes.
TheFrancaZ.
Twitch Emojis, die lange Zeit,
dich fühlen, dass du nicht allein bist.
Papa Pock Champ,
Kap ist Kappa,
Bible Thumb,
Twitch Emojis,
Peppern,
So, da bin ich.
Heute, spontaner, kurzer Stream.
1930, 1945 oder so ist auch schon wieder vorbei.
Ich habe auch keinen besonderen Plan.
Wir machen mit Niri wahrscheinlich nicht weiter.
Das machen wir bei einem gesonderten Stream.
wo das dann auch eben
zwei Stunden ungefähr, würde ich sagen.
So bis 19.45 Uhr
ist Maximum.
Ich kann nochmal kurz meine Pillen schlucken hier.
Kommt auch vor.
ob ich neo wie im stream jemals mache weiß ich ja nicht also okay chat was gibt's der
tommy schreibt ich habe auf der arbeit wirklich keinen bock mehr auf visual studio das kann ich
verstehen für sich ab was soll ich als alternativ einrichten will oder wie es
wissen rider bzw chat points geht leider nicht warum ist das damit ist es doch sogar mittlerweile
kostenlos wobei ich glaube es ist nur kostenlos für für non-commercials
aber es checkt doch eh keiner das überprüft doch keiner also ganz ehrlich
ich tippe darauf dass wishlist studio wahrscheinlich immer noch am besten ist
nebel rider
da müsste irgendeine lizenzprüfungsdude bei dir auf den rechner gucken im leben
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass irgendjemand sagt aber nicht sagen wir
nicht ich kann nichts dafür der max hat gesagt weil die aus wollen keine garantie
keine ahnung ich kann mir ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen wie die das überprüfen wollen es kann
auch sein dass du non commercial use machst damit du programmiert damit nur hobbymäßig
benutzt halt zufällig den gleichen Rechner
wie für die Arbeit, aber ich meine...
Und weißt du, was noch besser ist?
Weißt du, was noch besser ist?
Du kannst theoretisch die Trial von
Ryder, die kannst du
immer wieder resetten.
Indem du das...
Musst du mal suchen
danach. Du musst ein spezielles Verzeichnis löschen.
Dann resetet sich immer die Trial Period.
Was findest du besser?
neo wim oder wim ich habe da keine große präferenz weil meine wim config wartet mal kurz
ich habe schon gedacht hier golden cuppa am start ich habe da keine präferenz weil meine wim config
ist ziemlich minimalistisch kann die gleiche mal zeigen nachdem ich den mini pc hochgefahren habe
kurz die ist die ist keine ahnung 40 zeilen lang mit mit ein paar kleinen sachen drin
dementsprechend nachdem ich will also ich war ja früher eine hardcore user mit
1000 plugins und alle möglichen noch in zeiten bevor es neowim gab da war das
richtig abartig da waren das alles im script plugins die sich gegenseitig
teilweise gebissen haben und ich richtig miteinander funktioniert haben ganz ganz
schlimm und teilweise ultra leggy wenn man fuß da hat einer fassi fassi search
in dem script programmiert das war lahm alter und es war geruckelt
Es war ganz eklig und irgendwann habe ich mir dann gesagt, Max, Max, es hat doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, wenn du dein Wim so ultra customizest, weil dann gewöhnst du dich an deine Config und wenn du mal auf dem Server unterwegs bist, musst du dich wieder umgewöhnen.
Die hatte ich auch, Plugins von dem.
Klar, damals hat jeder T-Pope Plugins.
genau so und ach so mein logitech ich habe meine ich habe meine makros letztens disabled
das sind wir deswegen hier ist zu sehen
in firefox auf
ist sehen meine wimcon fick ist halt echt da ist mehr oder weniger nichts großartig drin
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr genau warum was das alles ist was in meiner
also okay, lass mal kurz gucken, ob ich meine
ob ich meine Wim-Config selbst
überhaupt noch checke, ja
äh
irgendwelche Syntax-Completion-Dinger
die ich nie verwende
Scroll-Jump, das ist glaube ich wie viel Platz oben und unten
ist beim Scrollen
oder so
äh, wie viele Spaces
für einen Tab
Shift-Width, keine Ahnung, Shift-Round
keine Ahnung, Expand-Tab, keine Ahnung
Smart-Tab, keine Ahnung
Set Number, dass vorne die Zeilennummer drin ist.
No
Hold
Enable
Ach, ich kann kein Codefolding
machen. Ja, okay.
Script Encoding, UTF-8, keine Ahnung.
Cursor Line ist das hier, dass der
aktuelle Zeile unterstrichen ist.
No Wrap, das ist, wenn es am Ende
des Terminals ist.
Also quasi hier.
Das ist dann nicht rumwrapped in die nächste
Zeile.
So, ähm, Ignore Case, wahrscheinlich für Suche und sowas, das ist Case Insensitive, Smart Case, keine Ahnung, Maus ausgeschaltet, dass man es ordentlich im Terminal verwenden kann, by the way, äh, Chat.
Warum ist denn meine Maus im Terminal wieder kaputt?
Ach
Weil ich hier gar nicht das selbst
Kompilierte Westterm hab
Okay, whatever
Ähm
So, Syntax Highlighting on
Kein Swap Files erstellen
Irgendwas für die Suche
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung
dass er sich die undo steps merkt profil und die history halt hier speichert dass ich aus
dem auto machen kann und 10.000 mal andere ich habe keine ahnung dass er sich merkt wo ich zuletzt
in der datei gewesen bin wenn ich sie schließe und dass der cursor hier wechselt guck also wenn ich
hier bin und drückt insert damit der cursor seht ihr also unterschied das ist das ansonsten ist
ist alles default ich habe da nichts großartig um gemap und das werde ich das
das werde ich auch nicht weiter um mappen weil jedes mal wenn ich auf den
server gehe vergesse ich sonst wie man will richtig bedient und das muss ja
nicht sein deswegen habe ich keine präferenz was
wim oder neo wirmen angeht
Worüber hier gerade die Frage war.
Chatterino.
Nee, Relative Linearm.
Was mache ich?
Ich benutze keine Wim-Motions.
Für Zeilen davor, Zeilen danach.
Oder so gut wie keine.
Katze Baumarkt.
Ich glaube, das kenne ich.
Nee, das kenne ich nicht.
Das ist wie das ZDF Instagram Format macht, im Hochformat.
Bei uns beim EDK ist auch eine, die immer da vor rum gammelt auf dem Parkplatz.
Ja, eine feine Katze ist es.
Ich finde wenigstens die Leckerlis.
Ich kenne bei uns genug.
Ich versorge hier alle Katzen der Nachbarschaft mit Leckerlis.
Die sind dann so blöd, wenn du denen hinwirfst, dann finden sie es nicht und so.
So muss das sein.
Ja, das habe ich jetzt ja beantwortet.
Ich habe da keine Präferenz, ob Neo-Wim oder Wim.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich Wim benutzen,
weil ich keine Zusatz-Configs habe
und das benutze, was halt standardmäßig dabei ist.
Was ja meistens eher Wim als Neo-Wim ist.
Was ist ein BKH?
Richtig kurz war.
Aha.
Ich würde alle Katzen nehmen.
Eine Stunde Heimfahren, dann viel Spaß.
Ich hoffe nicht mit dem Zug.
Weil das wird Pains Champ.
Dann wird aus einer Stunde mal schnell zwei Stunden.
Ich putte schnell noch nebenbei meinen Apfel.
Ich habe letztens gelesen...
Ich habe letztens gelesen, es gibt neue ESP32s.
Stimmt das?
Oder haben die Mist...
Ich habe ein YouTube-Video gesehen, glaube ich, war das.
wir haben gesagt es gibt neue sp 32 ja doch hier sp 32 p4 habe ich noch nie
gehört was das ist
360 megahertz 768 ram
64 MB Flash.
Das ist ja ein...
55 GPIO.
Das ist ja ein zweimal...
Okay, ey, das ist ja ein richtiges Power-Ding.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch alles andere als stromsparend, hä?
Weiß.
Gute Frage.
Bei Espressif ist es ja manchmal so,
dass die teilweise Dinge angeblich
releasen.
Alter, was wird dir wieder empfohlen?
Ich scrolle hier jetzt nicht runter.
26 Euro.
Boah.
Na gut.
Da ist ein Mobilfunkmodul mit oben drauf.
Bei AliExpress kostet so ein kleines Entwicklerboard 11,39.
Ja, die neuen Raspberry Pis, also es gibt jetzt ja wieder einen Vierer mit 3 GB, weil halt RAM so teuer ist.
Und das lohnt sich nicht.
Und ganz ehrlich, wenn ich sowas bräuchte,
dann würde ich mich, glaube ich, nur noch unter einer Bedingung
unter einer Bedingung für den Raspberry Pi
entscheiden. Und das ist,
wenn ich die GPIOs brauche,
weil ich irgendwas machen will,
was irgendeinen
Header braucht oder irgendwas, was
in die GPIOs angeschlossen wird und sowas.
Dann würde ich mich nach wie vor für den
Raspberry Pi entscheiden. Also wenn ich
was brauche, wo Linux draufläuft plus
GPIOs. Wenn ich nur einfach
GPIOs brauche, dann nehme ich den ESP32
Nicht unbedingt den hier, aber
sonst was. Und ansonsten
würde ich mir wahrscheinlich irgendeinen
Mini-PC kaufen
und mich freuen.
So, was haben die denn hier?
ESP32
H2
C3, C5,
C6. Ist das der mit
ZigBee? C5, einer davon
hat ZigBee.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Das Video scheint nicht zu stimmen, dass es da neue gibt.
Das ist wohl Blödsinn.
Gibt es neue ESP32 irgendwo?
Ich hatte letztens, wie gesagt, ein Video.
Vielleicht war das auch das von der CES, wo ich gesehen habe.
Also es gibt ja einen ESP32, es gibt einen ESP mit ZigBee, haben wir sogar im Stream schon mal verwendet.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau welcher, C6, C6 ist das.
Das haben wir im Stream verwendet und das hat auch echt ganz gut funktioniert.
Ich habe das hinten bei mir im Stall hängen, das Ding immer noch.
Und da ist ein Thermometer für den Fischteich dran.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt nicht weiß,
was ein guter
was ein guter Mini-PC
als Raspberry Pi Ersatz ist,
wenn man eben was Kleines
mit ein bisschen Power
braucht und
möglichst kompakt. Da kenne ich mich
nicht aus.
Der hat mal eine Weile richtig gute Videos gemacht für so Homelab-Equipment, was Netzwerk angeht und auch so Mini-PCs und sowas angeht.
Muss schon mal ein bisschen Ausschau halten.
Aber so Mini-PCs gibt es ja mittlerweile echt jede Menge.
Vielleicht
Nur bedingt Minisforum
Weil die Dinger sind einfach viel zu
Viel zu gut
Ja also die haben viel zu viel Power
Für das was man braucht und kosten dementsprechend auch mehr
Da würde ich mir irgendwas anderes raussuchen
Aber da gibt es ja zig solche Channels auf Youtube
Die sowas
Testen
Die kenne ich nicht
also das sagt mir was aber diese kiste keine ahnung es gibt ja auch noch ein
paar andere dinge also im raspberry pi formfaktor wobei da halt das ding ist
die sind teilweise auch nicht wirklich viel billiger und ja haben halt nicht
das ökosystem vom raspberry pi was halt ziemlich sagt weil wenn ich
raspberry pi formfaktor und raspberry pi will dann werde ich auch das ganze ökosystem von
raspberry pi ich brauche kein mini pc ging bloß darum dass raspberry pi so teuer sind
und bunt wird jetzt sechs gigabyte mindest rückwärts moment disk space oder ram
warum alter debian läuft auf irgendeiner kartoffel mini minimal ich glaube debian
selbst sagt 2 gig aber debian läuft wahrscheinlich auch auf auf also mindest
minimal db läuft wahrscheinlich auf 256 oder so
vermutlich für guia das kann natürlich sein wenn es für desktop mit gui ist ok
aber was ist denn mittlerweile so plaudert an ubuntu weil die sachen die
mir an ubuntu auf den sack gegangen sind sind einmal snap also das normale pakete die du über
app installiert auf einmal unter der haube snaps sind und ich mag nett plan nicht deswegen auf dem
server wenn es für mich privat ist debian beste auf der arbeit in der firma ist es halt red hat
kommst du nicht drum herum.
Hat mal irgendjemand bei uns entschieden,
muss Red Hat sein? Und die kaufen ja auch massig
Red Hat Lizenzen. Ich will nicht wissen, wie viel
100.000 oder was auch immer
die da an Lizenzgebühren an Red Hat bezahlen.
Ich hab prinzipiell erstmal
nicht nicht direkt was gegen snap was ich blöd finde ist wenn du denkst du installiert system
package und dann ist es ein snap zum beispiel dass die dinge halt standardmäßig im container
sind und die dann teilweise wenn du dateisystem mäßig darauf zugreifen willst die nicht die
konflikt dateien nehmen von den du denkst dass sie die nehmen oder wenn du darauf zugreifen willst du
von anderen ort muss und es ist also firefox ist ja mittlerweile auch ein snap standardmäßig selbst
das überhaupt installiert aber nicht auf dem server
ihr wisst ich bin arch boy arch linux fanboy arch boy aber nicht auf dem
server wir hatten das letzte letztens wir
haben letztens arch linux auf dem nass installiert um zu gucken ob es mit einem
Release Candidate Kernel
besser läuft,
was die Netzwerkkarte angeht.
Und das ist genauso
verbuggt mit dem Release Kernel wie sonst.
Gibt es WinGet auf Linux?
Nee, oder?
Nee.
Was?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung,
was es ist, aber ich glaube
nichts, was man braucht unter Linux.
Habe ich übrigens hinzugefügt.
Ich hab neue Emotes hinzugefügt.
Was gibt's zu futtern?
Toastbrot mit Käse drauf.
Rosinenbrötchen mit
Quark und Banane und ein Appel.
Installier mal
PowerShell unter Linux.
Nee. Ich weiß, dass es
das gibt.
Aber ich muss mich ja nicht zwangsläufig da irgendwie geißeln unter Linux.
Wobei ich sagen muss, PowerShell, ohne Scheiß, Leute, ich mag den Ansatz von PowerShell eigentlich.
Bei PowerShell ist es ja so, im Vergleich Chat, Chat, Frage an euch.
Ich weiß, wir haben ja viele Linux-Leute, ja.
Habt ihr schon mal PowerShell verwendet, um was zu automatisieren oder zu skriptoren?
Weil, wie gesagt, als interaktive Shell finde ich PowerShell Mist.
ja powershell hat ja ein bisschen anderen ansatz als bash oder zsh oder
fisch oder so bei linux ist es ja so wenn ich jetzt das hier machen das ist
text also der output von ls minus l a wird hier nach grepp gepiped das ist
einfach nur text bei powershell ist es so da sind hier objekte da geht nicht
Text drüber, sondern wirklich Objekte mit
Informationen. Das heißt,
in PowerShell, das ist jetzt Pseudo-PowerShell-Code,
weil ich keine Ahnung von
PowerShell habe, ja,
da könnte ich sowas hier machen, wie
findFile.keckel.txt
und dann könnte ich sagen
show.
size oder sowas, ja.
Das wird, sowas
könnte man in PowerShell machen, weil das
nicht Text ist, sondern Objekte sind, die hier drüber gehen.
Finde ich vom Ansatz her eigentlich extrem
Nice.
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Äh, ne.
Du durftest heute ein Enterprise-Netz
aufsetzen mit Unify.
Es stand, wird genau
Kunde wünscht Enterprise-Network
mit Unify, mit zwei
UDMs, sind das was?
Tree Machines.
ja dann hat er jetzt ein enterprise netzwerk das liegt wahrscheinlich daran
dass derjenige auf youtube videos geguckt hat und sich die videos von den
ganzen influencers angeguckt hat die unify komplett bis loben bis zum
abwinken und hat er sich gedacht ob das ist das profi equipment aber war aber im
ernst je nachdem was was sie hier haben wollen tut das unified zeug easy für
die
Und, und, dazu kommt, ich habe keine Ahnung von größeren Unify-Netzwerken.
Ich hatte selbst bei mir drei oder vier Unify-Access-Points bei mir daheim.
Aber die habe ich schon seit vor Jahren, habe ich das wieder abgebaut.
Habe jetzt was anderes.
Mir hat das nicht gefallen.
Und die Access-Points waren nicht so geil, von der Abdeckung her.
Und ich verstehe nicht, warum.
Obwohl ich wirklich mehr als genug hatte.
Was ist KMU in dem Fall?
Kleine und mittlere Unternehmen, oder was?
Die ganzen Abkürzungen immer.
Ja, okay.
Da hab ich aber noch Glück gehabt, ey.
Das sagt mir irgendwas.
Ist das nicht so ein Ding?
Wo der Kernel
aufverschleiert
oder randomize,
wo im RAM
Funktionen liegen zum Aufrufen?
Ne.
Ah.
Okay.
Ja, ey, fast. Fast. Fast.
Also ich mein, bei so vielen
Abkürzungen kann man schon durcheinander kommen.
Dann hab ich keine Ahnung, was Kasim ist.
Ist das was?
Für Kek-Assembler?
Pack Assembly.
Ach, ist das das, wo der Browser in dem...
Wo es Container...
Ja, das kenne ich.
Doch, das kenne ich.
Ich glaube, das habe ich sogar mal ausprobiert.
Das sah das aber noch hässlicher aus früher, oder?
Wie kann man das installieren?
Ich glaube, ich habe es sogar schon mal ausprobiert.
Hier.
Äh.
Chat, es geht tap down?
Tja, haha.
Microsoft sollte ein bisschen mehr in GitHub investieren als in AI.
GitHub ist...
GitHub ist down.
Excellent.
Geil.
Was machen die eigentlich in letzter Zeit?
Ja, guck mal.
Angeblich ist hier alles
ab. Gerade.
Das ist schon
mies, oder?
87,
93% Uptime.
Ja, aber das habe ich schon mal ausprobiert.
Das kommt mir jetzt, wo ich es mir angucke, kommt mir das bekannt vor.
Okay, jetzt ist die Seite ja auch komplett down.
Es geht gar nichts mehr.
Jetzt hängt es einfach nur noch.
Hat da einer den Loadbalancer rebooted oder? Oh, es hat geladen. Nee, hat's nicht.
Gateway Timeout. Nein, nein nicht. So, wir machen mal kurz Update und dann reboot.
Ist überhaupt ein Kernel dabei? Kein Kernel dabei, da müssen wir auch nicht rebooten.
Meinst du, es ist ein DNS-Problem?
Kann sein, intern bei denen dann, aber...
Es sind ja oftmals DNS-Probleme.
Ist bei dir wieder da?
Bei mir noch nicht.
Also die Projektseiten gehen anscheinend,
aber Profilseiten gehen nicht.
Ne.
Das ist broken.
Das GitHub ist kaputt.
Wieder weg.
Wanoji Bay. Na gut.
Kingwall,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Pog Subscription.
Da wäre ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Auf dieser
Übersichtsseite
war auch Co-Pilot, also GitHub.
Nicht Microsoft Co-Pilot, GitHub Co-Pilot drauf.
Und der hat auch
keine allzu krasse Verfügbarkeit gehabt.
Also merkt euch, Leute.
So sieht die Verfügbarkeit
von einem der größten
IT-Booten der Welt aus.
Von einem der
größten services der welt
ich glaube wenn wir auf der arbeit 89 prozent abteilen hätten
da hätten uns schon alle rausgeschmissen das meine ich ernsthaft
89% Uptime ist der komplette Witz.
Der Fairness halber muss man aber sagen,
dieser Uptime Graph ist vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt der aussagekräftigste,
weil
dieser Graph setzt sich zusammen
wenn alle Services
von GitHub ohne Fehler funktionieren
das heißt wenn einer dieser Sub-Services hier
einen Fehler hat
dann ist es hier oben halt
zählt es zur Gesamt-Uptime
wobei das auch irgendwo wieder fair ist
die berechnen die Uptime
von irgendwelchen Endpunkten
keine Ahnung
Also was wir unter der Haube genau machen, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, rot ist tatsächlich das Problem.
Aber ich glaube, diese Gesamt-Uptime-Zeit besteht...
Ist halt da, wo alles grün ist oder so.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest ist das echt mies.
Und auch die Werte sind auch nicht gut, ja.
Selbst wenn man sich mal...
Selbst wenn man sich mal die...
Ja gut, das ist die offizielle GitHub-Statusseite.
Was sagen die?
All systems operational.
Ist das so, GitHub?
Ist das so? Ah, es geht wieder.
Aber eben war nicht alles operational.
Da wollt ihr uns jetzt aber ein bisschen Mist erzählen, oder?
Dass da alles operational war hier.
Bei euch gilt ein System erst als down, wenn 15 Minuten nicht erreichbar ist.
Okay.
Also, bei uns gilt ein System als down, also ich kenne die offizielle Definition nicht,
aber für mich gilt ein System als down, sobald festgestellt wird, dass es nicht mehr erreichbar ist.
Also sprich, wenn das Monitoring meldet, irgendwas ist down oder im schlimmsten Fall irgendjemand anruft und sagt,
der kann da was nicht kann er was nicht erreichen oder wenn ich mich einloggen will stellfestes
antwortet nicht oder irgendwas guck mal bei eu was meinst du meinst hier eu github status
Nein, das Chat, wir haben uns das nur eingebildet
Es ist alles
Top
Operational
Überhaupt kein Problem gewesen
This is fine, Leute
Sagen die sich
Alter, was ist das für ein Emote
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass ich das hinzugefügt habe
Das sieht ja richtig dumm aus
Heckschur.
Tja.
Okay, Leute.
Nachdem ich keinen großen Plan
für den Stream heute habe, gucken wir mal,
ob YouTube
uns irgendwas empfiehlt oder
noch irgendwas haben, was wir uns angucken können.
Fünf geniale Ideen für ein
Smart Meter Chaos.
Warum Verbraucher draufzahlen.
Ey, ich hoffe ja, dass
sie irgendwann mal meinen Stromzähler
austauschen, dass ich den dann auch gescheit auslesen
kann. Aber die wollen ja nicht.
Die wollen nicht. Ich hab noch so einen ganz
alten Ferrariszähler.
Die peinliche
Antwort der Telekom.
Okay.
Wobei Space Frogs, das ist mir
wahrscheinlich
zu anstrengend.
Ich hab noch so ein Ding.
Kennt ihr die Dinger noch?
Oder hat vielleicht noch einer von euch so ein Ding?
Ich hab das, wie gesagt
Das Ding ist, das hat damals
Noch wahrscheinlich
Mein Opa mit dem Elektriker zusammen eingebaut
Oder so
Und das hab ich halt immer noch
Das ist von, keine Ahnung, 1950
Oder so
Und
Ich hoffe ja drauf, jedes Mal
wenn die wieder sagen, ah, jetzt machen wir hier Smart Meter.
Dass die mir endlich mal einen halbwegs gescheiten, modernen Stromzähler unten dran pappen.
Aber machen sie nicht. Die machen das einfach nicht.
Und die Dinger kannst du halt nicht richtig auslesen.
Ich hab's probiert, Leute. Ja, ich weiß, bevor jetzt einer sagt, doch, Max, da gibt es Sachen dafür.
Ja, ich weiß, dass das theoretisch geht mit sowas, aber das funktioniert nicht zuverlässig.
Kauf einfach einen Shelley und dann?
Und dann?
Kannst du nicht einfach einen eigenen Zähler einbauen?
Ne.
Also ich kann das schon mal gar nicht.
Die sollen das Ding mal wieder austauschen.
Doch, das gibt's alles.
Aber wäre doch viel geiler, wenn man einfach direkt den Stromzähler ablesen könnte.
So, was haben wir denn hier jetzt?
Wer kennt sie nicht?
Rent-Videos.
Ich hab so einen Hals, Leute.
So einen Hals.
Was, Rent-Videos?
So zu mieten oder?
Rent-Videos.
F*** die Telekom.
Telekom.
Doch, f*** doch mal.
Wir brauchen 5G an jeder Milchkanne.
Die Telekom hat tatsächlich auf unser Video geantwortet.
Für uns ist dieses Rant-Video über die Telekom ein guter Anlass, auch ein Video zu machen.
Nein, Telekom...
Okay, Chat, ich geb mir das Video mal zwei, drei Minuten.
Es könnte durchaus sein, dass mir das deutlich zu anstrengend ist und...
Das muss ich dann ausmachen.
Aber Telekom, Telekom-Rent ist immer gut.
Man kann ja auch genug renten bei der Telekom.
Guck das Original von der Telekom.
... Videos.
Ich hab so'n Hals, Leute. So'n Hals.
Die Telekom. Telekom. Doch, f***.
Doch mal, wir brauchen 5G an jeder Milchkanne.
Für uns ist dieses Rant-Video über die Telekom
ein guter Anlass, auch ein Video zu machen.
Denn über diese Themen
wollten wir sowieso mal ausführlich sprechen.
Moment, ich muss erstmal kurz in die Kommentare gucken,
weil das ist meistens das Lustigste dann da dran.
Die Kommentare laden aber
gerade nicht.
Ja, was? Wer hätte das gedacht?
Den Elefant im Raum werden sie wieder
nicht ansprechen, ne?
Was?
Sag mal!
Okay, komm.
Wer kennt sie nicht?
Rant-Video über die Telekom, ein guter Anlass, auch ein Video zu machen.
Denn über diese Themen wollten wir sowieso mal ausführlich sprechen.
Also, starten wir direkt mal hier.
Wir sind die drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt.
Aber nur Platz 59, wenn es um fest verbautes Internet geht.
und Platz 62 bei der Mobilfunkgeschwindigkeit.
Und damit sind wir Hinterländern wie Thailand, Vietnam oder Peru.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt,
aber ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen, dass das so ist.
Wenn wir uns dieses Ranking der Festnetzgeschwindigkeiten anschauen,
dann müssen wir uns auch die Voraussetzungen vor Ort anschauen,
die für den Ausbau gelten und wie diese Internetgeschwindigkeiten erreicht werden.
Klar über Glasfaser. Aber wie kommt diese Glasfaser ins Wohnzimmer?
In Thailand zum Beispiel so.
Wäre das in der historischen Altstadt in Nürnberg oder Rotenburg-Optertauber möglich?
Wohl kaum. Wollen wir aber auch nicht.
Aber in Deutschland diskutiert man...
Naja, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Ich meine, der hat jetzt da mal was rausgepickt.
Und ja, andere Länder nehmen es da teilweise auch, wenn man sich anguckt, wie da Elektrik-Zeug verlegt wird.
Sicherlich nicht so ernst wie wir.
Ja, also, dass das teilweise da abenteuerlich ist oder so, will ich ja gar nicht bestreiten. Aber als an sich ja, sagen wir mal, Land, was zumindest ein bisschen Kohle hat und was auch immer, sagen wir mal, fortschrittlich dastehen will, haben wir die letzten, ja, wie der Chat sagt, 20 Jahre schon erstaunlich wenig gemacht.
Also in der Zeit hätten wir schon deutlich mehr machen können.
Wir haben ja auch teilweise angefangen,
aber dann wurde es ja wieder komplett abgebrochen.
Es gab ja teilweise früher schon Glasfaser.
Leider war es was, was man heute nicht mehr verwenden kann.
Man hat einfach nichts gemacht.
Man hat so lange auf DSL rumgeritten,
bis es nicht mehr anders ging.
Also hätte man schon viel mehr machen können, ja?
Und in der Zeit hätte man sicherlich dann auch die Sachen
ordentlich und da, wo es ein bisschen schwieriger ist,
verlegen können.
Heißt jetzt ja nicht, dass wir alles über irgendwelche Zäune hängen müssen oder so.
... für jedes Glasfaserausbauprojekt mit einer Vielzahl an Behörden über jegliche Details im...
Ja gut, dass wir zu viel Bürokratie haben, da gebe ich ihm recht, das ist so.
Das ist ja absolut lächerlich teilweise, was du da alles machen musst.
Das ist affig, das stimmt schon.
Bis hin zu der Frage, ob die Glasfaser statt 60 cm unter der Erde auch mal 40 cm tief liegen darf, damit der Ausbau schneller geht.
Diese Bürokratie kostet Zeit und Geld.
Rund 70.000 Euro zahlen wir aktuell für den Kilometer Glasfaser-Tiefbau.
Das geht in Thailand schneller und wahrscheinlich auch günstiger.
Hinzu kommt der Markt an qualifizierten Kräften für den Glasfaserausbau.
meine ist die hatten früher im osten fragt mich nicht mehr wie das hieß schon einiges
glasfaser gelegt aber damit kann man heute nichts machen kann man heute nichts mehr anfangen
ob
chat bin verwirrt wo ist das video da
in deutschland fast leer gefegt deswegen haben wir sogar eine eigene tiefbau firma ist in
deutschland fast leer gefegt deswegen haben wir sogar eine eigene tiefbau firma gegründet die dt
tiefbau gmbh so richtig mit eigenen baggern schaufeln und tiefbauen und so der noch schneller
ausbauen zu können über 12,8 millionen haushalte können wir man muss aber dazu sagen das ist ja
alles schön und gut das hättet ihr vor 20 jahren aber auch schon machen können hätten wir nicht
DSL bis zum Umkippen
weitergeritten.
Und so komische Regelungen, wie wir teilweise
in Deutschland haben und hatten,
dass wenn irgendwo der Ausbau gefördert
wird, für die, boah, frag mich nicht,
nächsten 10 Jahre an der gleichen
Stelle kein Ausbau mehr gefördert
werden darf und so komisches Zeug.
Wann macht die Telekom so ein YouTube-Format?
Ja, anscheinend, weil sie mal auf das
Rent-Video antworten wollten.
Durch diesen Glasfaserausbau
heute schon ein Gigabit
Glasfaseranschluss anbieten.
Über 34 Millionen Haushalten
können wir mehr als 100 Mbit anbieten.
Und über 25 Millionen
Glasfaserausbau
heute schon ein Gigabit
Glasfaseraanschluss anbieten.
Moment mal.
Über 12,8 Millionen Haushalte
können wir durch diesen Glasfaserausbau
heute schon einen Gigabit-Glasfaseranschluss anbieten.
Ich meine, das klingt jetzt erst einmal viel, ja.
Aber wie viele Haushalte gibt es denn in Deutschland?
Okay, also kommen wir ungefähr in den Viertel.
Ungefähr in den Viertel.
Das erscheint mir jetzt allerdings auch ein bisschen viel,
ein bisschen hochgegriffen, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber selbst ein Viertel ist nicht viel.
Man darf nämlich nicht vergessen, richtig spannend wird es dann, wenn du dort, wo ein bisschen weniger bebaut ist, wo ein bisschen weniger Leute pro Kilometer oder Quadratkilometer wohnen, wenn du da die Versorgung sicherstellen willst.
Dann wird es schwierig.
So die ersten paar Prozentdinger, die erreichst du immer schnell.
Über 34 Millionen Haushalten können wir mehr als 100 Mbit anbieten.
Ja, das heißt im Endeffekt, du bist kein Content-Creator, der Sachen hochlädt.
Du benutzt den Internetanschluss hauptsächlich alleine.
Ja, du streamst nicht in fünf Räumen gleichzeitig.
Das reicht das schon.
Aber bei einer Familie reicht das oftmals schon nicht.
10 down, 40 up.
Echt, DSL war früher 100 down, 5 up.
Ist das mittlerweile 40 up? Wirklich?
bei VDSL vielleicht, ja.
Ja.
Also wie gesagt, früher war das 100
da und 5 ab.
Weiß nicht, wie das ist.
Könnte er auch ein bisschen genauer
sagen können.
Aber wenn man jetzt eine Familie mit
zwei Kindern ist,
da kann das durchaus schon ein bisschen
knapp werden, ja.
Die Kinder gucken YouTube, die Mutter guckt, was gucken Mütter denn hier, Traumschiff oder so, per Stream, Vater hat Twitch laufen, sitzt am PC und macht noch irgendwas, Homeoffice, irgendein Videocall.
also 100 Mbit klingt jetzt erst einmal viel
da kommt man aber auch an die Grenze
dann lädt sich da so noch irgendwie
gerade ein neues Game runter über Steam
oder auf die Konsole, also das ist jetzt
nicht so, dass man sagt, das ist ja
Luxus, ja
und es ist halt immer wieder
die reine
Zahl
an sich
sagt noch relativ wenig
drüber aus, wie flächendeckend das verfügbar
ist. Weil
es ist ganz klar, ne? Stellt euch vor,
in der Haus legt ihr eine Leitung
an ein Hochhaus und habt ihr auf einen Schlag
keine Ahnung
30 Leute angeschlossen.
Ihr legt ein bisschen
auf dem Landenkabel an ein Haus,
da habt ihr drei Leute angeschlossen.
Also in den bisschen weniger
stark besiedelten Gebieten
ist das immer schwierig.
Und sowohl bei Glasfaser
als auch bei
Bei allem, bei jeglichem Ausbau.
Deswegen ist die reine Anzahl immer kein guter Indikator für, wie flächendeckend wirklich alles ist.
Und über 25 Millionen Haushalten in Deutschland rund 250 Mbit.
250k ist zu wenig. Das ist nach heutigen Standards zu wenig.
Mit diesen 250 Mbit, die über 25 Millionen Haushalte haben können, kann man übrigens gleichzeitig
Ja und? Dann machen wir einen Game Download nochmal an.
Parallel. In einem Haushalt.
Aber ja, es gibt tatsächlich noch Haushalte, denen wir...
Hä? 250 MBit ist in der Regel wird's reichen.
Sag ich auch gar nichts dagegen.
In der Regel wird's reichen.
Sofern man nicht auf irgendwelche Services bei Cloudflare zugreifen will.
Aber ansonsten, wie gesagt, mach einen Game-Download an, lass die Leute streamen, lass die Leute vielleicht noch Homeoffice machen dabei.
Also du kommst da mit einer Familie und zwei Kindern, kommst du da durchaus schon in Spitzenzeiten mal dran.
Aber in der Regel reicht das schon.
Leider nur 16 MBit anbieten können.
Wie viel?
Es gibt tatsächlich noch Haushalte, denen wir leider nur 16 MBit anbieten können.
Und das sind in ländlichen Gebieten wahrscheinlich, ich habe lange nicht mehr auf den, wir können aber bei der Gelegenheit gerade mal gucken, Breitband Atlas.
Schon eine Weile nicht mehr drauf geguckt auf den Breitband Atlas.
Das sind ja hauptsächlich ländliche Gebiete.
So.
Äh.
Verfügbarkeit, alle Technologien...
Nee.
Äh...
Ich will mobil.
Man kann da keinen Mobilfunk mehr rausfiltern.
Ach nee, Festnetz.
Ah, die haben das jetzt getrennt.
Okay, noch besser.
Noch besser.
Die haben das jetzt getrennt.
Früher war das hier...
Okay, das...
Also 10 Mbit gehen überall.
16,
30,
50,
100, ja.
Und gerade wenn man dann hier
auf ländliche Gebiete und so geht,
so was weiß ich mal, hier unten irgendwo so am Marsch der Welt,
ne, da siehst du halt hier schon,
da hast du halt immer mal wieder solche Flecken.
In ländlichen Gebieten.
Deswegen, so die reine Anzahl sagt immer relativ wenig, wie flächendeckend das Ganze ist.
Macht uns das glücklich?
Nein.
Aber abgesehen davon, dass das dann keine über 70 Euro im Monat kostet, hat man hier
oft die Möglichkeit mit einem Hybrid-Router, Festnetz und Mobilfunk.
Ja hör mal Plus auf, das ist ja der größte Schrott ever, alter.
für mehr Bandbreite, also schnelleres Internet, zu bündeln.
Haben wir auch im Angebot.
Ja, das ist schön für euch, dass ihr das im Angebot habt.
Aber ganz im Ernst, mobiles Internet,
und auch wenn das irgendwie gebundelt ist,
das ist wahrscheinlich okay, wenn man ab und zu mal was streamt.
Aber wenn du irgendwas online spielen willst, ist abfuck.
Wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte, ich weiß nicht,
ich weiß nicht wie gut
diese Hybrid-Router sind
ob die
in der Lage sind
Game-Traffic
quasi zu priorisieren
sodass der immer über die Leitung geht
und
nicht Mobilfunk
technisch, das weiß ich nicht wie schlau
die Dinger sind, aber
sagen wir mal so, wenn man die Auswahl hat
zwischen 16 Mbit oder 16
Mbit plus Mobilfunk, ja klar
dann würde ich auf jeden Fall 16 MB plus Mobilfunk nehmen.
Aber ich finde es trotzdem abartig.
Um diesen Vergleich besser zu verstehen,
muss man sich anschauen, wie Daten für solche Rankings erhoben werden.
Dafür schauen wir uns jetzt mal etwas genauer Deutschland
und zum Beispiel Peru und Vietnam an.
Hä? Moment, das habe ich nicht ganz gecheckt, um was es geht.
In Deutschland, einem Flächenland, also einem Land, in dem Menschen über die komplette Fläche verteilt leben, werden Messpunkte für solche Vergleiche von Mobilfunknutzern über das ganze Land verteilt gesammelt.
Also eben auch an der Küste, im Schwarzwald oder im Allgäu.
In Peru hingegen sieht man, dass ein Großteil der Messpunkte im Wesentlichen in einer großen Stadt zustande kommen.
Ja, wir müssen jetzt ja nicht beweisen, dass wir irgendwie besser als Peru sind oder dass Peru wirklich besser als... Ja, das glaube ich dem ja auch. Aber das sollte jetzt nicht unser Anspruch sein, zu sagen, ah, vielleicht sind wir gerade mit Ach und Krach besser als Peru. Wir sollten top der Welt sein.
zumindest mit dem, was wir so
Geld
einnehmen.
Wobei das meiste ja für Altersvorsorge
und Krankenversicherung drauf geht.
Aber wir sollten ganz vorne mit sein
und nicht irgendwie uns fragen, ist Peru
besser oder sind wir noch gerade knapp besser als Peru?
Das kann ich mir durchaus,
ich glaube, das wird stimmen, was
er sagt, dass das nicht so fair ist,
wie man das vergleicht an der Stelle.
Aber ich habe sie jeden Tag,
also es ist jetzt so typisches, wie sagt man, wie nennt man das
ähm
so persönliche
Erfahrungen verallgemeinern
ich hab jeden Tag, wenn ich
nach Frankfurt fahr, ich fahr nicht jeden Tag nach Frankfurt
aber jeden Tag, wenn ich nach Frankfurt fahr
hab ich
zwischen
Hanau
und Frankfurt
da liegt mein Tal dazwischen
ja, mein Tal
Karte
Hanau
hier, Maintal,
da fährt ein Zug durch,
wahrscheinlich ist das hier die Zugstrecke oder so,
ja, genau, Wilhelmsbad,
das ist Hanau noch,
und dann kommt irgendwo hier, kommt dann Maintal
und so, so, äh,
Maintal, genau, so,
hier, ich hab hier diese
Strecke,
Maintal Süd,
Maintal, äh, nicht Maintal Süd,
Maintal Ost, Maintal West,
bis Frankfurt Main, Kurbis,
bis Frankfurt Main, habe ich
keinen Handyempfang.
Hier, mitten, mitten,
drinnen.
Der Fairness halber, ich bin noch nicht bei der Telekom.
Aber ich war früher
bei der Telekom.
Als ich auch das alte Diensthandy hatte, da war das auch.
Und in Vietnam sieht es ähnlich aus.
Von daher hinkt der Vergleich
der Mobilfunkmessungen und Geschwindigkeit
Ich meine, man muss ja sagen,
Sie haben sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben bei dem Video, besonders ruhig, sachlich und überzeugend und glaubhaft seriös rüber zu kommen.
Denn vereinfacht gesagt ist das eigentlich ein Stadt-Land-Vergleich und kein Länder-Ranking.
Und in Städten ist es nun mal einfacher, schnelle Mobilfunkgeschwindigkeiten zu ermöglichen als auf dem Land.
Ja, das ist mit dem Ausbau übrigens genauso.
Oder im Wald oder in den Bergen. Aber vergleichen wir mal nicht Äpfel mit Birnen, sondern Äpfel mit anderen Äpfeln.
Vergleichen wir mal die Mobilfunknetze europäischer Flächenländer, die zumindest ähnliche topografische Herausforderungen im Ausbau haben wie wir.
Das hat die Zeitschrift Connect gemacht. Gemeinsam mit dem Spezialisten Umlaut hat sie die Qualität und Abdeckung der Mobilfunknetze in Deutschland.
Ist das, ich stelle das jetzt einfach mal in den Raum, ist das nicht das, was von der Telekom gesponsert wurde, diese Untersuchung?
Müssen wir mal nachgucken, ja.
Es gibt ja oft mal so Dinge, wo dann das Ergebnis im Vorfeld schon feststeht.
Aber keine Ahnung, ob das so ist.
Müssen wir mal nachschauen, ja.
Ich will das jetzt denen ja auch nicht unterstellen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum er über Mobilfunk labert.
So genau checke ich es auch noch nicht.
Standorten in Deutschland zufrieden und ruhen uns darauf aus?
Natürlich nicht.
Wir brauchen kein 5G an jeder Milchkanne.
Doch, f*** doch mal, wir brauchen 5G an jeder Milchkanne.
Das hätte ich jetzt wahrscheinlich etwas anders ausgedrückt.
Aber ja, wir sind auch noch nicht zu 100% zufrieden.
Da muss man aber mal eins zugute halten oder Telekom.
Die haben ja teilweise da auch mit sehr merkwürdigen Sachen zu kämpfen.
Leute, die keinen 5G-Ausbau wollen, weil Strahlung und solche Dinger.
Da greife ich mir auch immer an den Kopf.
Aber gut, gibt es in allen Bereichen.
Auch wir wünschen uns 5G an jeder Milchkanne.
Und deswegen...
Die große Preisfrage ist, ob die die Cloudflare-Problematik nochmal ansprechen.
Wir haben ja schon in den Kommentaren geguckt, wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Ja, dass das mit Bürokratie und Aufwand und Genehmigungsverfahren, dass das in Deutschland Abfuck ist, das ist schon so.
des Masts vor Ort, der Anbindung mit Strom und Glasfaser, was übrigens auch über Tiefbau
geschehen muss, bis hin zu den Aufhängen der Antenne sowie der Abnahme durch die entsprechenden
Behörden. Wir suchen auch weiterhin Standorte für Mobilfunkantennen. Wenn du ein geeignetes Dach
oder eine Fläche für uns hast, dann melde dich gerne unter telekom.com slash mobilfunkstandort.
Denn wir möchten gerne noch mehr bauen.
Telekom ist in sehr vielen Ländern vertreten und so auch in den USA.
Das stimmt, die Telekom macht sogar bei E-Sport-Veranstaltungen in den USA Werbung.
Also 40 Milliarden hingeblättert haben und dort jetzt überall Glasfaser anbieten.
Danke, dass diese Privatisierung dazu geführt hat, dass in andere Länder investiert wurde, aber nicht in Deutschland.
Fuck yeah!
Ähm, ich kann da nicht allzu viel sagen jetzt im Fall von der Telekom, aber wusstet ihr, dass das bei der Bahn teilweise ähnlich ist?
Dass die teilweise sonst wo dabei rum beteiligt sind und dabei rumwurscheln, bloß nicht, dass der Zug fährt in Deutschland?
All diese Mobilfunkmasten und Glasfaserkilometer, über die wir gerade sprachen, das sind übrigens Investitionen in Deutschland, hier in Deutschland.
Wir haben über 40 Milliarden Euro nur in den letzten 10 Jahren investiert. 5,9 Milliarden Euro allein davon im letzten Jahr.
Dass wir also nicht in Deutschland investieren, das stimmt nicht.
Ja, da sieht man, damit bestätigt der ja indirekt, dass einfach eine ganze Zeit lang einfach nichts gemacht wurde.
Wenn ein so hoher Prozentsatz von der Gesamtsumme allein schon letztes Jahr war.
Das heißt, die machen erst so richtig, was die letzten fünf Jahre.
Davor ist halt nichts passiert.
Unser Netz.
Außerdem, genau, 40 Milliarden in zehn Jahren sind nicht viel.
In fünf Jahren könnte man durchaus sagen, oh, da habt ihr aber ordentlich ein bisschen was ausgegeben.
Ist so gut eben, weil wir investieren.
Nur ihr nicht zu verbessern. Weil wenn wir darüber reden wollen, warum das Internet in Deutschland so schlecht ist, dann müssen wir auch über eine bestimmte Firma reden.
Ja, lass uns über diese bestimmte Firma reden und darüber, ob das Internet wirklich so schlecht ist.
Natürlich hat hier jeder seine...
Ja, wenn man Dienste benutzen möchte von der Telekom aus, die hinter Cloudflare sind, hat man da öfters mal ein paar Problemchen, ja.
Äh, was ich jetzt gehört habe, aber das kann ich natürlich nicht aus eigener Erfahrung bestätigen, also keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich ist, dass auch Telekom-Kunden öfters Probleme Richtung Twitch haben sollen.
Eigene Meinung. Ich würde es aber gerne etwas versachlichen. Deswegen lasst uns mal auf Quellen schauen, die es wirklich untersuchen und testen. Und da sieht es gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Was juckt mich denn 5G und Mobilfunk in dem Fall? Wir haben jetzt ja lange genug drüber geredet.
Test-Siegen und Auszeichnungen gibt es aber natürlich auch die Kundenerfahrung.
Und die sind im Netz der Telekom auch nicht schlecht.
Über 100.000 Leserinnen und Leser.
Das stimmt wohl, die anderen sind noch beschissener.
Das ist tatsächlich so. Also bei der Telekom würde ich mich noch am ehesten drauf verlassen.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass es toll ist, aber die anderen sind noch schlechter.
... haben im Frühjahr 2025 abgestimmt und der Telekom ein starkes Zeugnis ausgestellt.
Gleich mehrmals sichert sich die Telekom bei der Umfrage den ersten Platz.
Unter anderem als bester Mobilfunknetzbetreiber und als führender Anbieter im Festnetz.
Ein beeindruckendes Ergebnis.
Wie gesagt, die anderen sind ja noch beschissener.
Das zeigt, wie sehr Qualität und Verlässlichkeit von unseren Kunden und Kunden geschätzt wird.
Und wenn eine Verbindung dann eventuell doch mal ruckeln sollte, dann kann das auch an dem Anbieter des Contents liegen, der seine Daten...
Das stimmt. Das darf man nicht vergessen. Da gäbe ich ihm recht.
Da gäbe ich ihm recht.
das wird oftmals außer acht gelassen, wenn sich die Leute auf so eine Sache eingeschossen haben,
dann ist jedes ruckelnd, oh das muss an der Telekom liegen.
nachlesen kannst online sehen weil sie möchte ranger marketing und mal ganz
davon abgesehen also ich bin jetzt nicht der große
der große internet
routing protokoll kenner
Kannst du als Anbieter wirklich bestimmen, komplett wie dein Traffic läuft?
Kannst du nicht?
Du kannst sagen, hier, ich übergebe das jetzt an den hier.
Und wie es dahinter weitergeht, hat der Anbieter noch überhaupt keinen Einfluss drauf.
aber über BGP sagst du doch auch, da kannst du, also wie gesagt, ich kenne das auch nur aus,
ich klicke in Packet Tracer rum und sowas, da kannst du autonome Netze einstellen,
so wer mit wem und wo angeschlossen ist und du kannst auch Prioritäten vergeben,
aber kannst du wirklich sagen, mal angenommen, du sitzt jetzt irgendwie in München
und du willst ein Paket nach Island verschicken,
dann übergibst du das erstmal deinem Provider.
Da hast du erst einmal danach gar nichts mehr zu sagen,
was dein Provider damit macht.
Wenn du jetzt selbst der Provider bist,
dann bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz sicher.
Aber kannst du da wirklich sagen, wenn jetzt irgendwie beim dritten Hopp nach deinem Netz,
ob das dann der Anbieter, der dafür zuständig ist, weiter über Russland schickt
oder über ein Kabel in der Nordsee, da hast du doch dann keinen Einfluss mehr drauf, oder?
wie willst du es auch machen?
Der Umut kennt sich damit aus,
das weiß ich.
Der sagt,
du bestimmst über das
eBGP die Routen zum Ziel mit,
du übergibst den Traffic,
dann halt über einen längeren Weg.
Also du kannst damit wirklich komplett
bestimmen,
wo dein Traffic lang läuft.
Wow.
Ja gut.
Und wenn die Telekom dann sagt,
über diesen Weg
ist es super teuer, dann nimmst du halt
den Scheißweg.
Chat, ich glaube, wir müssen irgendwann mal
in Packet Tracer
ein BGP-Netzwerk zusammenklicken,
dass ich da besseren Durchblick habe.
Was sagt ihr dazu?
IP-Leak?
nee, ich mein
Impact Tracer, das ist ja nur
simuliert
ich auch nicht großartig
naja gut
aber wie gesagt, da kann ich qualifiziert nicht allzu viel
dazu sagen, wie das genau
Ihr wollt Glasfaser haben. Wir wollen Glasfaser bauen. Dafür müssen wir aber auch eine neue
Glasfaserleitung in das Haus oder in die Wohnung legen. Oft durch einen Vorgarten über ein
Grundstück. Oder der Vermieter sagt kein Bock. Und wir haben die Erfahrung gemacht,
dass viele Kunden es hier einfach schätzen, wenn man dort über den Ausbau spricht, wo
wo er auch stattfindet, vor der eigenen Tür.
Ach, es geht um die Marketing, Leute.
Ja, ist klar.
Die Marketing, das sind die Schlimmsten von der Telekom.
Die klingeln bei mir auch manchmal.
Die haben mir auch letztens erzählt,
ich bin reingegangen an die Türgegensprechanlage,
haben die mir auch erzählt, hier wird demnächst Glasfaser ausgebaut.
Da habe ich dann drauf gesagt,
ich gucke mal im Internet nach, ob das stimmt.
Und dann waren sie wieder weg.
Die Ranger, Leute.
Denn hier ist es einfacher und praktischer Verlegungswege zu besprechen, als es nachzulesen
oder online zu recherchieren.
Aber natürlich gelten auch hier für diese Beratungsgespräche ganz klare Regeln.
Bis hin zu der Regel, wer keine Beratung möchte, kann ganz einfach Nein sagen.
Aber dazu gerne auch mehr unten in den Links.
Wo wir uns einig sind.
Wir alle möchten mehr Geschwindigkeit, mehr Ausbau und mehr Abdeckung in Deutschland.
Dafür suchen wir kontinuierlich nach Wegen, schneller und besser zu werden.
Ja gut, das ist so ein bisschen Selbstlobreisung.
Zum Beispiel mit einer eigenen Tiefbaufirma, mit Kampagnen, um Mobilfunkstandorte zu finden,
mit massiven Investitionen in Deutschland.
Aber letztendlich ist es wie vieles andere auch ein Miteinander von Politik, Gesellschaft, Kunden und insbesondere
Wir haben leider zu spät angefangen.
... den Firmen, die Netze ausbauen.
Und je fairer das Miteinander ist, desto produktiver kann es sein.
Ja, wir machen Fehler, denn Menschen machen Fehler.
In Summe viele, denn wir haben Millionen von Kunden.
Prozentual gesehen machen wir zum Glück immer weniger Fehler.
Und wenn ihr euch ärgert, dann meldet euch.
So schlecht war das Video jetzt auch wieder nicht.
ähm, ja
ich
ich fände es schön, wenn er zu der
Cloudflare-Thematik was gesagt hätte, aber das
äh, schweigen der überall tot
ähm, beziehungsweise ich fand's
witzig, auf Twitter
wo dann irgendeiner vom Telekom-Support
mal geantwortet hat, ähm
dann mach's doch über VPN oder sowas
wobei, das
das fand ich vollkommen okay, ne
dass die den Shitstorm da abbekommen hat
fand ich nicht richtig, die kann ja auch nix dafür
Die hat eigentlich nur was gesagt, was wirklich hilft, ja.
20 bis 50 Cent pro Terabyte.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das viel ist.
Ich habe da überhaupt keine Erfahrungswerte.
Aber wenn du das sagst, glaube ich immer, dass das viel ist.
Genau, die hat wenigstens gesagt, was funktioniert.
Chat, irgendwie, wisst ihr, was ich gerne machen würde?
Ich würde mir gerne jetzt noch, wir haben ungefähr noch 45 Minuten Zeit,
oder 50, sag mal 50 Minuten für den Stream Zeit.
Ich habe irgendwie Bock auf C++ Flame.
Können wir uns das heute zumuten?
Oder eher nicht?
Wir können auch
was anderes gucken
Aber irgendwie hätte ich Bock auf 10++ Flame
Aber wo davon wird es in Zukunft auch nicht besser
How I became a Linux Kernel Contributor
Das können wir mal angucken.
Das ist glaube ich gar nicht so uninteressant.
Den Kanal gucke ich mega gerne.
Das sind die Leute, die früher GCN auf Deutsch gemacht haben.
Die haben jetzt einen eigenen Kanal.
Also wer gerne Fahrrad-Content guckt auf YouTube, kann ich das nur empfehlen.
Die sind auch dafür verantwortlich, dass ich meine...
Ne, die haben neue Presenter jetzt, GCN.
Also das deutsche GCN.
Die haben jetzt zwei neue.
Die sind auch dafür verantwortlich, dass ich...
Was ist denn das hier?
Dass ich Kettenwachs damals drauf gemacht habe.
Und jetzt bin ich da echt zufrieden mit.
Das englische GCN...
Ich gucke die eigentlich alle ganz gerne.
Ich gucke GCN, ich gucke GCN Tech oder wie das heißt.
und ich guck auch Triathlon GCN
ich meine ich guck da jetzt irgendwie super religiös jedes Video
aber schon regelmäßig
Umut schreibt wir schieben knapp 600 Terabyte im Monat
hab beim Tippen zu schnell getippt meinte 200 Cent bis 500 Cent
also rechne das mal durch
Nur von der Telekom Pakete kriegen darfst, was es kostet.
Okay, das klingt teuer.
Aber ich bin jetzt gerade am überlegen,
ist das Peering teurer oder wenn ich Festplatten kaufen würde?
Wenn ich Festplatten kaufen würde.
Also am besten alles buffern auf geschuckten SSD-HDDs
und dann per Post schicken.
Was Fluchtursache Handyempfang hat.
Ach, das ist...
Das ist vor sieben Jahren.
Das sieht aber anders aus aktuell.
Wir haben immer noch ganz schön viele Zuwanderer.
Ich glaube, wir haben mittlerweile 18 Millionen.
Wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe.
18 Millionen Leute hier, die in Deutschland leben und, also die keinen deutschen Pass haben und in Deutschland leben.
Ich glaube 18 Millionen, irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Ja, aber eins muss man mal sagen, teilweise sind die Cloud-Traffic-Kosten auch echt keck W.
Ich sehe das teilweise, was wir bei uns auf der Arbeit bei Google bezahlen, da schüttelst du echt nur den Kopf. Und nachdem ich ja hauptsächlich da im Bereich Blockchain aktiv bin, in der Versicherung, da kommt einiges an Datenmengen zusammen.
Gerade wenn mal irgendwelche
Notes neu gesynct werden müssen
Oder teilweise Backups
Restored werden müssen und sowas
Das haben die glaube ich immer noch
Dieser Festplatten LKW
Ich glaube das gibt es immer noch
Das gibt es glaube ich immer noch
Amazon Snow
Dieser LKW mit den Festplatten
Ach ne wurde eingestellt
Ach.
Ähm, weil Google...
Also WestEurope 3C, oder WestEurope 3, besser gesagt, Region, bei Google ist halt in Frankfurt.
Und bei uns auf der Arbeit ist halt zu 90% alles bei Google in der Cloud.
Wie werden Blockchains in Unternehmen eingesetzt?
Also, ich kann dir nichts zu Eigenentwicklung sagen, Blockchain.
Bei uns geht es um Finanztransaktionen auf Blockchains.
Oder nicht, Finanztransaktionen ist glaube ich die abstrakteste Beschreibung, die man da geben kann zu.
Also nicht um irgendwelche eigenen Anwendungen, die irgendwas komisches auf der Blockchain speichern oder so.
Wir waren sogar letztens in den News.
Wieso nicht eine normale DB?
Ja, weil du vielleicht mit Leuten auch handeln möchtest,
die nicht an deine Datenbank angeschlossen sind.
Und da hängt noch ganz viel anderes Zeug dran.
Wobei ich mir da jetzt nicht sicher bin,
wie weit ich das im Detail erzählen kann.
Ich musste letztens erst wieder eine Compliance-Prüfung machen.
Und da geht es genau um solche Fragen, woran man Geldwäsche und sowas erkennt.
Und eines der Punkte ist, glaube ich, auch bei verdächtigen Herkunftsländern und sowas.
Stand da drin.
So, Leute. Ich muss mir jetzt eine Runde C++ Flame geben.
Das geht nicht anders.
Jetzt wird es eklig.
Tu es nicht.
Doch.
Moment.
Wo habe ich denn mein Textdokument?
Sekunde.
Ich habe doch hier irgendwo
Notes
C++
Sackt.
Habe ich doch hier irgendwo als Textdatei.
Okay.
Ich habe hier was drin stehen.
Ich habe hier eine Textdatei, die nennt sich C++ sagt.
Und da habe ich mir als obersten Punkt aufgeschrieben.
undefined behavior c++ con 2024 talk.
Der da?
Und dann?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es das...
Minute 10, 17.
Was passiert bei Minute 10, 17?
Ah, das ist 2023, okay.
Undefined
Okay, keine Ahnung
Dann weiß ich nicht, was ich mir da aufgeschrieben hab
Naja
Egal, ich muss mir jetzt, Leute
Ich muss mir jetzt C++ geben
C++ Flame geben, auf geht's
Wir haben den Anfang schon mal geguckt
Aber ich habe schon wieder alles verdrängt.
Und außerdem...
Ich muss jetzt endlich mal mein Brötchen futtern hier.
Beziehungsweise mein Toastbrot futtern.
Jetzt...
Das Video ist wirklich gut.
Ich kenne das schon.
Ich habe das schon geguckt vor einem halben Jahr oder so.
Als es rausgekommen ist.
Hat er eigentlich noch mehr?
Noch mehr Videos dazu hochgeladen?
Ne.
Der hat einen YouTube-Channel gemacht, nur um eines der epischsten C++-Rants hochzuladen.
Okay, let's go.
C++ ist absolut atrocious.
Zuerst einmal gibt es 20 verschiedene Wege, eine Variable zu initialisieren.
Und es gibt so viele Regeln in Edge.
Leute, man könnte jetzt denken, er hat sich hier extra was rausgepickt.
So nach dem Motto, ja, das geht, das macht doch keinen...
Nein, das ist wirklich so.
Das ist wirklich denial ernst.
Und diese
Krankheit, die sie da haben,
dass die quasi
alles als extra
Typ und extra Funktion
irgendwie in STD
packen, anstatt mal
zum Beispiel die String-Klasse
ordentlich zu machen, dass du die halt auch
verwenden kannst.
also anstatt anstatt in c++ ist ja so anstatt dass es vektor sort oder sowas gibt oder vektor
punkt filter oder vektor punkt map oder sowas gibt es dann standard filter oder irgendwie
sagt das so eklig alter die rote 300 textbücher das ist ein topic ist aber
everything in c++ ist ein mess consider the task of printing something to the
console most languages have a simple print function to do das kann man es dann
auf alles anwenden naja wie wärs denn wenn man einfach bei
den standard typen jeweils eine filter oder map funktion definiert oder aber
noch besser die dinge kriegen eine gemeinsame base class
wo das definiert ist.
In C Sharp machen sie es ja auch so.
In C Sharp gibt es ein Interface,
wo diese ganzen Sachen drauf definiert sind.
Es ist ja nicht so,
dass in C Sharp List und Map und sowas,
dass das alles die Dinge nochmal selbst definiert.
Und dann hat Back Inserter.
Alfred, das gefällt dir das, ne?
Das sagst du jedes Mal.
Aber in C++ musst du...
Ja, das stimmt echt
Moment
Nee, nee, nee, nicht in C++
Wobei mittlerweile, der Fairness halber
Muss man sagen
Was es gibt, std2, wirklich?
Seit wann gibt es das dann?
Kenn ich nicht
Wusste ich nicht
Ähm, mittlerweile gibt es sowas.
Es gibt mittlerweile FMT-Lib, die wurde mittlerweile in die Standard-Library aufgenommen.
Also das ist halbwegs gescheit mittlerweile.
Das ist schon eklig.
Hier ein weiteres Beispiel von C++'s Schlechtigkeit.
so auch also die sind da die sind da rechts rechts hat ich das kurs generating erinnert
am bau randem in c++ pass mal das wird richtig aber sich jetzt in python you just call random
In Java ist es ähnlich.
Ich putte ein Toastbrot mit Käse drauf.
In C Sharp ist es ähnlich.
In C++ ist das irgendwie
8 Zeilen Aktion.
Das ist ein
Mersin Twister.
Das ist irgendein Algorithmus, wie du eine Kette von Pseudo-Random-Dingern kennenkriegst.
Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist so eklig, man.
Das haben die Leute von Espressif auch erkannt, weil
die haben einfach selbst was implementiert,
weil die Standard-Library suckt,
wie du eine Random-Number kriegst.
Ja Mo, das stimmt schon.
Aber es ist ja noch nicht mal
das ist irgendwie einheitlich.
Das wirkt immer so,
als haben dann halt irgendwie 15 verschiedene
Leute an 15 verschiedenen Features
entwickelt und nix passt
zusammen.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Wenn ich diese Syntax da ausgedacht habe.
What the fuck?
Ja.
Standard Chrono Duration Cast
von meiner...
Standard Chrono Duration Cast, Standard Chrono Microseconds, 200, äh, WTF, Alter, es gibt, es gibt Sprachen, da kann man sowas hier machen, so, keine Ahnung, blub, gleich, Date, Time, äh, Keckel, und dann sagt man, blub, two, was weiß ich, äh, oder, keine Ahnung, Seconds, two Milliseconds, irgendwie sowas, ja, also,
Ah, das ist halt wieder
schlimm.
Naja, was soll das?
Oder was soll das sein?
Das mag schon sein, ja.
Aber
andere Programmiersprachen kriegen das ja auch hin.
Frag mal die Rust, Leute.
Rust ist da deutlich konsistenter.
Rust ist auch nicht schön zu lesen,
wenn es das komplette Feature-Set
von Rust benutzt. Also Rust kann auch
sehr, sehr eklig aussehen.
Aber es ist konsistenter.
Oh ja.
In Java, you just put things in parentheses.
In C++ gibt es irgendwie fünf verschiedene Dinge.
Und wisst ihr, ich check es halt nicht.
Warte mal, wir müssen das Beispiel ankommen.
Ich check es halt nicht.
Warum musste man das ausschreiben?
Static Cast, was gibt es da sonst noch?
Reinterpret Cast, Autocast.
Gibt es Autocast überhaupt?
Reinterpret Cast gibt's auf jeden Fall.
Ey, das ist so
eklig, Alter.
in allen Szenarien. Manchmal musst du
DynamicCast, ReinterpretCast,
ConstCast oder BitCast verwenden,
abhängig von der Konzentration.
quasi namespace ist oder ist konst kasten keyword und standard bitkasten nicht
was genau was genau ist jetzt eigentlich so schlimm an
der geschichte hier ja ich verstehe warum es die anderen dinge irgendwie gibt das macht ja für
dich schon gewisse checks ob der typ konvertierbar ist und sowas das hier ist ja bei c also dieser c
style cast ist ja im prinzip einfach nur neben diesen speicher hier interpretiert ihn jetzt
als in fertig oder so kann es auch hier sagen ja das ist jetzt point dazu nimmt
das war ursprünglich war einem pointer zu einem string ist egal konzentration
machen
aber ich finde die syntax trotzdem nicht verkehrt
...be familiar with your version of the language,
so it's best not to do this.
And that's the thing that's so jarring about C++.
Correct, C++?
Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Es gibt ja hier diese, finde ich persönlich gar nicht mal so schlechte Syntax,
aber man kennt es auch aus anderen Sachen, genau wie Java zum Beispiel.
Wenn du eine Instanz von einer Klasse anlegen willst,
dann schreibst du new davor.
finde ich vollkommen fein.
Auch irgendwie recht elegant, gut lesbar.
Man könnte es noch mit Auto verwenden,
dann musst du das nicht mal mehr vorne hinschreiben.
Also ich finde ganz ehrlich, diese Syntax hier,
wenn du sagst Auto, blub, gleich,
New, blub, das finde ich vollkommen fein.
Das ist super.
Aber das soll man ja nicht mehr verwenden, den C++,
weil das ja RAW-Pointers sind.
Und RAW-Pointers sind ganz böse.
Und dafür gibt es jetzt eine abfackegliche Syntax.
Haha.
in einer anderen Sprache lernen.
Das Problem ist, dass du all diese Keywords
wie externen...
da weiß ich zumindest teilweise teilweise was es macht extern verwendet man für sachen die gar
nicht bei einem source code drin stehen so wenn man von irgendeiner anderen library was rein
link oder so und davon keine heller falls hat und irgendwie so kannst du dann quasi sachen
aufrufen, die irgendwo anders definiert sind.
ConstExpo
ist CompileTimeCheck.
Const
ist ein fester Wert,
der sich nicht verändern kann.
Ich habe allerdings wiederum keine Ahnung,
was sich da zu Static
unterscheidet.
Wahrscheinlich brauchst du Static als Modifier
bei Methoden von Klassen.
Und Inline ist, glaube ich,
mittlerweile relativ irrelevant.
Und du hast verschiedene idiomatische Kombinationen von ihnen, die auch ihre eigenen Regeln und Bedeutungen in verschiedenen Situationen haben.
Was ConstExpr kann CompileTime sein, muss aber nicht.
ConstEval muss CompileTime sein.
Moment, Chat. Da gibt es zwei unterschiedliche paar Sachen?
Ich dachte immer, ConstExpr ist CompileTime.
Aber natürlich, wie sollte es in C++ auch anders sein,
ist das nicht so einfach, wie man sich das vorstellt.
C++ aggressively repurposes existing keywords in inconsistent ways.
Das Statik-Keyword hat zum Beispiel drei oder vier Anwendungen,
abhängig davon, wie man es zählt.
Der erste ist, Variablen zwischen Funktionen zu verändern.
Der zweite ist, Klass-Variablen zwischen verschiedenen Instanzen zu teilen
oder Klass-Funktionen zu kreieren, die unabhängig von jedem Instanz existieren.
Aber der dritte Anwendungsfall ist ein komplettes Semantik-Nonsequenter.
Es ist verwendet, Funktionen privat zu machen,
oder eher unabhängig von außen der CPP-File, die sie definieren.
Was?
Das ist ein Ding? Das geht?
Das war mir überhaupt nicht klar.
Aber heute in der Zeit sind Kompilierer smart genug, das automatisch zu tun,
also hat die Anwendung des Inline-Keywords für diese Grundlage keine Werte.
In diesen Tagen wird Inline genutzt, um...
Das habe ich auch so im Kopf, dass man Inline eigentlich nicht mehr schreiben muss.
... Probleme mit der Ein-Definition-Regel.
Das lustige hier ist, dass das Anwendung von Inline auf eine Funktion
das gleiche Gegenteil von Anwendung von Inline auf eine Variable macht.
In beiden Fällen lösen sie Probleme mit Ein-Definition-Regeln,
aber eine Funktion mit Inline führt zu möglicherweise vielen unterschiedlichen Instanzen
of the function across the binary,
whereas an inline variable makes sure that there is only
a single instance of the variable in the whole binary.
Additionally, you can also make a namespace inline.
This is typically used for library versioning.
Inline namespace?
Was zum Teufel soll das überhaupt bedeuten?
Wenn ich das lesen würde, wüsste ich noch nicht.
Ich würde, ganz ehrlich, wenn ich das lesen würde,
würde ich vermuten, das kompiliert nicht,
weil es einen Sonntagsfehler gibt.
Das ist es.
Ja, stimmt.
Das finde ich ja auch geil.
Dass Overwrite optional ist.
Ich hätte auch gedacht, das ist ein Muss.
Aber sonst erkennst du ja gar nicht, dass du hier Funktionalität von deiner Base-Klasse überschreibst.
Oh, das ist nicht schlecht hier.
Unsigned long long int.
Moment, sehe ich das richtig?
Dass eigentlich long long, long long int und signed long long, signed long long int,
dass das alles das gleiche ist?
Also die ersten vier ist quasi das gleiche.
Warum kann man nicht einfach schreiben
Uint64T
anstatt diesen Kack hier?
Ja genau, hier, das da. Ne.
Was zum...
Uint Least
64T? Was?
Was soll denn das jetzt schon wieder sein?
Was?
Was ist Least?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Was ist Fast?
Fastest unsigned integer type.
Wie fastest.
Fastest?
Das ergibt ja überhaupt nichts.
Wenn ich es lese, selbst mit der Erklärung dahinter,
habe ich absolut keine Ahnung, was es bedeuten soll.
Also least verstehe ich ja noch.
Least check ich noch.
Du bekommst was, was mindestens 32 Bit hat.
Es kann auch 64 sein, 32, whatever.
Aber fast, fast 32T?
Also die Dinger hier kenne ich.
Die benutze ich auch viel lieber als diesen Krempel hier.
U in 64T.
Warum überhaupt T?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht genau.
Ich vermute mal, das ist, dass es keine Name-Collisions oder so gibt.
Dass man da noch ein T hintendran gehängt hat.
Ursprünglich dachte ich eigentlich, dass diese Sache mit UN64T eine Linux-Sache ist.
Ich dachte, das kommt von irgendeinem Linux-Header.
Aber anscheinend ist es Standard.
Ja, das heißt, ich denke auch, dass das Typ heißt, ja.
This is for backwards compatibility reasons.
On 64-Bit Linux, long is 64-Bits.
The names are also just so verbose and ugly.
I hate...
Wie gesagt, deswegen schreibe ich lieber Uint32T und sowas.
Weil hier mit Paste wird durch.
I wish we could all just agree to use something terse, like I64, in the case where we want 64-Bits.
So, wieso macht das übrigens Rust?
Again, you could technically create your own aliases, but it's ill-advised.
And I hate how fixed-width integer types have an underscore-T suffix.
I mean, come on guys, we're not in the 90s anymore.
Beginners also find it weird how getting the size of standard library data structures returns a size T instead of an integer,
which can also be of various sizes depending on the hardware.
At some point you'll inevitably run into the...
Oh je.
Enden wir bloß auf mit Standard String und so Zeug.
Da kriege ich auch Anfälle.
Die Standard String Klasse ist...
Letztendlich ist es ein Byte Array.
mit ein paar Helper-Funktionen,
die aber auch nicht bei jedem String funktionieren.
Aber Standard String ist eines der schlimmsten Dinger überhaupt.
zwischen einer Standard-String und einer W-String?
Was sind die Probleme?
White Characters
Default Chart Rate Allocate
Moment, was?
Das Ding ist auch geil
Du liest, das finde ich bei C++ auch gerne
Du liest C++ Hilfe-Seiten
und du verstehst danach noch weniger
als vorher
Okay, Wecha
Microsoft erklärt uns das jetzt
Wecha
Ist ein implementierungsdefinierter
definierter Breitzeichentyp
Zeichentyp!
Okay, Moment, Leute.
Wo kann man das nochmal umstellen?
Äh.
Englisch.
Gibt es nicht einfach...
Gibt es nicht ganz normales Englisch?
United Kingdom.
Implementation define white character type.
Okay, im Microsoft Compiler sind es 16 Bit.
Die machen es da aber auch echt kompliziert.
Übrigens, da muss man echt mal sagen,
ich mecker ja auch mal ganz gerne an Rust rum,
wie umständlich da Sachen sind und sowas,
aber ich finde String Handling machen die echt ganz gut.
Das ist standardmäßig einfach alles UTF-8.
Strings in Rust sind immer UTF-8.
Das heißt, UTF-8 hat ja einen riesen Vorteil,
nämlich UTF-8, also zwei Vorteile,
also noch mehr, aber so zwei große Vorteile.
Das erste ist, UTF-8-Encoding kann alle Unicode-Zeichen darstellen.
und das nächste ist,
die ersten 255
oder sind es 128 Zeichen?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher. Aber die ersten
Zeichen sind die gleichen wie bei ASCII.
Das heißt, du kannst
dein 99%
Textausgaben-Kram machen wie mit
einem ASCII-String, aber du kannst
auch so Sachen wie Emojis und sowas reinhauen.
Also ich finde, die machen das richtig.
Das ist eines der Sachen, wo ich
Ich finde C Sharp, ach ja, und es ist
die, mit die effizienteste
Art, wie du das speichern kannst.
Ja, ich finde C Sharp macht das nicht
so schön. C Sharp arbeitet intern
mit 16 Bit
pro Character.
Also mit UTF,
was ist das dann, UTF-16 oder sowas?
Das kommt aber noch aus Zeiten,
weil die Sprache entstanden ist
zu einer Zeit, wo es diese ganzen
Unicode-Standards und Encoding-Standards
noch nicht so wirklich fest waren.
Ja.
Ich finde das,
ich finde das Handle-Trust auch ganz gut.
Du musst es halt
explizit da aufrufen.
Also du musst dann sagen,
es ist dann kein
UTF-8-String,
sondern, wenn du das
Wenn du eine Datei einliest oder sowas,
kriegst du dann ein OS-String oder sowas in Rust
und da musst du dann explizit sagen,
convert to UTF-8
und dann weißt du, okay, wenn das klappt,
dann hast du auch einen gültigen UTF-8-String.
Wenn das nicht klappt, musst du die halt irgendwie in den Default-Case,
also musst du den Fehler quasi schon handeln,
anstatt dass du dir selbst da irgendwie was ausdenken musst.
Ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut, wie die das in Rust machen.
Wie gesagt, das ist nicht alles schön in Rust,
aber diese dinger kommen mir doch durchdacht vor
deswegen die damit umgehen die das ja die sagen nicht einfach nur der dateiname ist jetzt quasi
den standard rust string und dementsprechend utf 8 und was machen wir du kriegst dann quasi
so einen abstrakten
OS-String, heißt das glaube ich bei Rust.
Also quasi das, was halt nicht
standardmäßig auch was anderes
sein kann als UTF-8.
Und da musst du explizit sagen, Convert to
oder sowas.
Damit umgehen die das. Das heißt, du kannst
dir dann aber auf jeden Fall sicher sein,
wenn du den als Standard
Rust-String hast, dann ist es gültiges
UTF-8.
Und
du kannst dich dann darauf verlassen.
Und du kannst damit dann halt auch so Sachen machen,
wie
to lower und sowas.
Wobei ich auch sagen muss, Standard
String ist jetzt nicht so geil.
Ich finde die
Ruby String Klasse, die Default String Klasse,
finde ich ganz gut.
Rust String, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob Rust sowas wie Partition
hat. Ah, du hast Standard
String Partition.
Hast du sowas?
Ah, gucke mal, gucke mal da.
Also, Split
String.
die Rust-Standard-Sachen
sind teilweise gar nicht so kacke.
Aber die Standard,
also was mir bei Ruby immer echt gut gefallen hat,
ist die Standard-String-Klasse.
Da hast du wirklich alles drin,
was du brauchst hier.
Capitalize,
Center,
Trimmen
Zusammenhängen
Zeichen löschen
Jeder Code Point
Also da ist direkt hier
Unicode Support dabei
String Empty, Encoding
Partition
Index von rechts
Also so finde ich, so muss eine
Full Featured
String Klasse in der Standard Library
Aussehen, wie bei Ruby
Chat ist 19.30 Uhr.
Muss jetzt gleich auf C++ Rant machen wir dann in einem der nächsten Streams,
weil ich sonst nichts zu tun habe, weiter.
Ich muss mir merken, wo wir gewesen sind, weil ansonsten fangen wir das nächste Mal wieder von vorne an.
Wir waren bei 6 Minuten 54.
Das kann man doch hier irgendwie speichern.
link share kann man so machen start at das suche ich genau
56 das guckt dass das kann ich mir merken ich bookmarks mir auch noch mal dass da wissen wir
da haben wir aufgehört.
Wir gucken
nicht alles. Der hintere
Teil gibt es einiges zum Überspringen.
Ja, das worüber Gui Frameworks
rantet, das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Finde ich, ist auch
wirklich so, wie er das sagt.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht so spannend.
naja, da könnte ich bei C-Sharp
und Gui Frameworks und Microsoft auch drüber
ranten.
Die tun sich ja auch keinen Gefallen damit.
Also
deswegen können wir eigentlich froh sein dass es bei der netz so was wie avalon ja mittlerweile
gibt dass man wenigstens ruhigen gewissens sie schafft auch für cross-platform desktop
anwendungen verwenden kann bei microsoft hat er selbst keinen bock mehr auf native
anwendungen nicht umsonst das startmenü eine react anwendung
Ja
Chatkin
Komm, in 10 Minuten haben wir noch Zeit
Gibt es noch irgendwas Spannendes
Okay, anscheinend nicht mehr.
Dann machen wir Bastelstream mit dem GSM ESP-Bot.
Nee, das bestelle ich mir nicht.
Minimaler AI-Coding-Agent.
Juckt mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so.
Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall ein deutscher Entwickler.
Die hört sich ein bisschen an wie ein alter Kollege von mir.
Es gibt eigentlich eine Menge Informationen über Pi selbst.
Das wird später...
Komma, es gibt wieder Updates, jawoll!
Wir haben am Anfang des Streams Updates gemacht und am Ende des Streams machen wir nochmal
Updates.
So wie sich das gehört für Archlinux.
Da muss alle Viertelstunde geupdatet werden, sonst ist das alles nicht aktuell genug.
Guck mal hier, Chaterino, Bäm!
Ach Quatsch.
Power off.
Bäm!
Weg ist.
Bam.
Alles klar, Chat.
Dann, schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid.
Richtig random, sinnloser Stream heute.
Aber besser ein Stream als kein Stream.
Denke ich mir zumindest so.
Und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Stream.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.
Nee, oder?
Oder wollen wir?
Ich muss noch die
Ich muss noch die Kampagne auf Nightmare
durchspielen.
Mit dem zweiten Charakter.
Mit dem ersten
hab ich schon alles durch.
Okay,
ich überleg's mir, RF-Programmer.
Machen wir vielleicht.
Ich hätte eigentlich auch mal Bock drauf.
Wobei, das hat dann am Ende halt nur 30 Zuschauer, aber ich mein,
was soll's.
Bis dann, tschüss.